former Vice President Joe Biden could be
on the brink of announcing a run for the
White House CBS News has learned he
started to tell potential donors about
his plans early polling shows Biden is
at the top of an already crowded field
of 14 candidates running for the 2020
Democratic nomination Ed O'Keefe is in
Washington with what Biden may be
worried about heed good morning good
morning Nora after nearly accidentally
announcing his plans in a weekend speech
several people familiar with the former
vice president's plans tell CBS News
that Joe Biden has started phoning
potential donors this week who could
help him raise millions of dollars fast
part of Biden's challenge is that unlike
Bernie Sanders bet too O'Rourke or
Kamala Harris he's never really had a
vast national network of supporters
willing to donate money online so it's
unclear if he'll be able to raise big
money on day one the number to beat is 6
point 1 million dollars that's how much
O'Rourke raised on his first day as a
candidate last week Sanders raised about
5.9 million dollars on his first day and
as Biden starts phoning donors top aides
are starting to interview potential
staffers and all signs still point to an
announcement at some point in mid-april
Nora all right and I have to ask you
about this we saw senator Kamala Harris
the latest Democratic hopeful to say
she's open to abolishing the electoral
college but as you know that would
require a constitutional amendment tough
to pass a supermajority of
three-quarters of the states as well as
a House and Senate vote so why are they
pushing for this well because in some
states they're actually already
seriously talking about this 12 states
and the District of Columbia
totaling 181 electoral votes already
have laws that would award electors
based on the national popular vote
instead of the statewide vote but those
laws would only take effect once other
states join in and they reach a total of
at least 270 electoral votes the number
needed to win the White House more than
a dozen other states are debating this
issue this year Republicans though
including the president say this is a
bad idea because they believe it would
be presidential candidates to ignore
smaller and rural states we'll see right
on focus on the more populous Democratic
leaning states Eadie thank you